hi there Steve Kaufman here again well
we three of my power language learning
where I'm trying to learn three
languages every day and make sure that I
save 100 links create 100 links in other
words look up 100 new words every day in
each of the languages I have to admit
it's getting a bit of a becoming a bit
of a chore to make sure that I get those
hundred every day I'm gonna show you
some snapshots of my profile to show you
that I am more or less keeping up to the
hundred a day I think I had a day or two
here and there where I wasn't able to
I can use my coins that link to maintain
my Street whoops dropped my little
remote here for controlling the video so
and then I looked at my statistics and
when I show you the the profile in fact
I can show you one now let's just take
you know Persian if I show them the
three of them now Persian Turkish and
Arabic give you a five second look at
each one of them the basic idea is that
I am keeping up to the hundred links
created every day however I have less
time now for each language so given that
I only have about an hour or so of
listening time available an hour an hour
and a half that's when I you know make
breakfast do the dishes workout in the
gym I'm on my bicycle those kinds of
things I mean there's only so much of
that time so obviously I I'm listening
less to each language than I when I was
focused on one so what I want to talk
about today is controlling the things
that you can control not worrying about
the things that you can't control so
obviously I am listening to less say
Arabic then if I were only learning
Arabic so therefore my to that extent I
will progress more slowly in
Arabic then would otherwise be the case
that's just a fact that there's only so
much time I have available I'm not going
to spend three hours a day listening to
the three languages in order to make up
for the fact that I have to divide my
listing time into three the same is true
of all the other activities I am forcing
myself to study three languages I am
creating 100 links every day looking up
a hundred new words in order to control
to make sure that I in fact do spend
time on each language and so I find at
the end of the day if I have only got 30
links created in Turkish I'm gonna have
to sit down and find some content with a
lot of blue or unknown words which isn't
difficult and then go through and create
a hundred leagues so that's what I'm
controlling now I can't control for
example when I'm going to learn a word
so some of the words that I've saved
before like I don't know in Arabic for
example Aztecas Asti Saha I can never
remember the word for econ STC is desaad
if this ax I don't know I can't remember
I see it and every time I see it it's
like a new word for whatever reason that
word doesn't want to enter my brain I
can't control that I don't worry about
it in time in time it'll sock in so
that's one reason for example why I'm
not a big fan of spaced repetition
systems because I don't believe that
given sort of frequency of reviewing
something based on some algorithm is
going to determine when I learn it I
learn it when I learn it and so that's
another reason why people say well how
can you possibly save a hundred new
words every day how can you keep track
of them I don't worry about keeping
track of them I can't control that I can
control the fact that I look up a
hundred words in each language every day
that I can control I can't control how
frequently I will see those words and
even a word that I see very frequently
in Arabic because I'm listening to a lot
of sort of political discussions and
there are words that come up all the
time
I mean I'm getting lots of frequency of
economics politics words you know
demonstrations things like to have and
some of those words even with the same
amount of frequency some I remember some
I don't I don't worry about it I can't
control that all I can control is that
I'm gonna try to listen equally to all
three languages everyday but it tends to
be that I'm you know more on one
language than the other it looks like my
Turkish is suffering I can't even
control the fact that at link we have
text-to-speech for Turkish and Arabic
but we don't have it for Persian which
makes it more difficult to learn Persian
I can't control the fact that the
Persian text seems to get distorted on
my iPad app which doesn't happen with
the Arabic and Turkish our technical
people are looking into it so I have to
study the Persian on the computer which
is less convenient for me than doing it
on the iPad but I can't control that so
fine one of the things that's important
to is when I do spend whatever I managed
to put in everyday you know I can't
control if my wife wants to go play golf
I mean we're down here to play golf she
likes to play golf I can't say sorry I'm
gonna try and put in an extra three
hours today on language to try and get
caught up like that can't really control
that so I operate within the limits of
what I can control I am able to do
create a hundred links a day that I can
control I know that in time gradually
I'm getting better I understand more and
more of these political podcasts in
Arabic I also can't control for example
if they have a podcast in Arabic some
people speak more clearly than others
some people drag in Egyptian or Iraqi
Arabic in there supposedly Standard
Arabic discussions I can't control that
in the I was listening to Faro and
Persian and for the last long while they
were talking about the they were talking
about this sort of
nuclear program in Iraq in Iran and
things of that nature with a lot of
technical terms you know which wasn't
very interesting to me but still that's
what I have available I'm using the
Fargo but now that they've had these
demonstrations in Iran surrounding the
increase and the price of gasoline I
find that a little more interesting
vocabulary and more useful so I'm
learning from that kind of content maybe
you know unfortunately in Persian
there's not a lot of resources out there
in French or Spanish or Russian or
Japanese maybe there's a greater variety
of things that I could use I have to
deal with what's available to me the
other thing that I can control is to
tell myself you know what you are doing
is worth it learning languages learning
Persian Turkish and Arabic is a
worthwhile activity even when it's
frustrating even when you keep on
forgetting the same words I know that I
will eventually learn the language I
think it's a worthwhile activity I think
that my method of learning is effective
so I just keep going so I can control my
attitude I can to some extent control
the amount of time I put in I like
having goals that I can control like a
hundred links every day I can control
that but I can't control how quickly
I'll learn I can't control when words
will stick I can't control when certain
aspects of the grammar will stick I can
only control what I do so I think it's
important in language learning to focus
on our activities our level of activity
the kind of activity we engage in and
not worry too much about the outcome
because to some extent the outcome is
not within our ability to control now
remember if you want to receive my 10
tips to language learning a series of
ten emails please click on the link that
you see here and that's what I have to
say look
your comments bye for now